GOOD MORNING
AND WELCOME TO THE JANUARY
TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE. WILL BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT A QUORUM IS
PRESENT I HAVE MEMBERS IN OF THE
COMMITTEE ARE MONITORING THIS
HEARING PLEASE COME TO ROOM FOR
FORCE THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
POINT. DO THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
WITH MODIFIED COMMITTEE
PROCEDURES. FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT AT
TODAY'S HEARING SOCIAL
DISTANCING IS REQUIRED IN THE
AUDIENCE. OF THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS PRESENT. IN THE HEARING ROOM
MUST WEAR A MASK OVER YOUR MOUTH
AND NOSE AT ALL TIMES. WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYBODY IN THE PUBLIC IS ABLE
TO TESTIFIED THE COMMITTEE
INCLUDING TESTIMONY BY PHONE IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
PAYING AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE WITHIN OUR TIME LIMITS
. WE WILL NOT TOLERATE ANY.
DISRUPTIONS OR CONDUCT THAT IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THE COMMITTEE
PROCEEDING DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR
BEHAVIORAL THAT INSIGHT OR
THREATENED BY INCLUDING VEILED
THREATS IS PROHIBITED. PLEASE BE
AWARE. THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL
. THE COMMITTEE HAS FOR BILLS ON
ITS AGENDA TODAY. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
COMPLETE ITS BUSINESS AND A LOT
OF TIME WE ARE LIMITING PLUS
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS FOLLOWS FREE
TO BUILD WILL BE A MAXIMUM OF
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
. TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WITH A LIMIT OF TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS. AFTER WE
HAVE HEARD FROM THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES WE WILL HAVE A MAXIMUM
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
. AND FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION FOR EACH BILL. OTHER
WITNESSES ARE LIMITED TO
PROVIDING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT IF
ANY AND THERE ARE AND THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL. ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS WILL BE RULED OUT. IF
YOU'RE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH
THE PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THIS WRITTEN TESTIMONY
WILL BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD FOR EACH BILL. FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WATCHING THIS HEARING
REMOTELY AND WISH TO CALL IN TO
REGISTER THEIR POSITION. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN
AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR. FOUR FOUR.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY ALEXION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR COMPUTER SCREEN IF
YOU WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE BACKGROUND NOISE. THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTS ONYOUR SMART DEVICE.
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION.
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH
THE MODERATOR PHONE SERVICE. YOU
CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
AT NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
1-149-163-1920 NINETY FOUR. AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO TRY TO
HELP. THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. JAN THIS
INCREDIBLY TRYING TIMES. IT'S A
QUORUM PRESENT NOW. MEDITATOR WE
CALL THE ROLL BRIAN. THE PRESS
BRIAN HERE C. R. TELL SERGEANT
HERE BENNETT BENNETT HERE LOW.
CERVANTES MULLIN MULLIN HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. FOR PROCEED TO OUR
AGENDA AT TO ADDITIONAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE FIRST THE
SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES. EIGHT TODAY TO
REPLACE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD
MAYES FOR THE PURPOSES OF
TODAY'S HEARING. CERVANTES WHEN
SHE GETS HERE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. SECOND I HAVE A LOT.
FOR SANTIAGO ASKING THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN BE
PERMITTED TO PRESENT AB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN ON HIS BEHALF- ACCEPTED
THAT LETTER SO SOME MEMBER
MULLIN WILL BE PRESENTING THAT
BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WITH THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS THE WAY
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEES. BUSINESS FIRST ITEM
ON THE AGENDA IS AB TWO TWO
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. GOOD MORNING.
CONGRATULATIONS ON BEING THE
FIRST TIME IN WEEKS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO PRESENT- THIS YEAR TO
THIS COMMITTEE WELL SEE. YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWO TWO SEVEN I FIRST
WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
MEASURE FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
SPECIFICALLY NICOLE BECKER I
WANT TO START OFF BY SAYING I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSALS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOWED TO APPOINT INDIVIDUALS
TO VARIOUS BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
. I WANT TO START UPS SAYING
THAT. SKEWS LAW THE GOVERNOR'S
ALLOWED TO POINT INDIVIDUALS TO
VARIOUS BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE HOWEVER
EXISTING LAWS SILENT ON WHETHER
OR NOT THE GOVERNOR SHALL
DISCLOSE ANY. ON IF THOSE
APPOINTEES EVER CONTRIBUTED TO
THE GOVERNOR OR PACS SUPPORTING
HIM OR HER IN RECENT YEARS
LEGISLATORS HAVE PASSED NUMEROUS
CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE LAWS TO
ENSURE FOR INDIANS HAVE THE MOST
UP MOST TRANSPARENCYCOMMISSIONS WITH SENDING HIM
IDEAS AND HOW TO ELIMINATE UNDUE
INFLUENCE IN THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND OUR GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE.
AB TWO TWO SEVEN TAKES THIS TO
HEART AND WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC
DISCLOSURE BUT THE GOVERNOR
DURING THE ANNOUNCEMENTS OF ANY
APPOINTMENTS AND ANY APPOINTEE
IF THEY MADE A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR MORE. IN THE TWELVE
MONTHS PRECEDING THIS
APPOINTMENT THEIR APPOINTMENT
DISCLOSURE COULD BE DONE
VERBALLY OR IN WRITING. THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL'S NOT TO
NEGATE ANY APPOINTMENTS BUT TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS UNDERSTAND
WHAT QUALIFICATIONS AND RATIONAL
LEAD TO APPOINTMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. MEMBERS WILL I WISH
I COULD TELL YOU THAT PAY TO
PLAY POLITICAL CONTRIBUTIONS DO
NOT HAPPEN. WE HAVE INSTANCES
FROM BOTH DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS BUT IT
DOES. FOR EXAMPLE IN OUTLINED BY
THE L. A. TIMES BANKER MARC
BERMAN AN ATTORNEY AT WILEY
ATKINS EACH CONTRIBUTED THE
MAXIMUM TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED TO GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN SELECTION. IN TWENTY TEN
BEFORE HE POINTED THEM TO COVER
THE POSITIONS ON THE STATE
PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSIONS AND
CALIFORNIA ARTS. COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER ALSO PHONE TO
HAVE APPOINTED POLITICAL
CONTRIBUTORS TO POSITIONS MOST
NOTABLE ON THE DEL MAR FAIR
BOARD FOR INSTANCE STATE RECORDS
SHOW. OVER PERIODS OF FIVE
YEARS. FIVE SEATED BOARD MEMBERS
WERE FINANCIALLY DONORS TO SORTS
**** DOUGLAS BARNHART AND HIS
WIFE. PLUS EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM GAVE A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. KIM
FLETCHER AND HIS COMPANY
INVESTORS LISTEN CARP GAVE A
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED. KELLY BURKE GAVE A
HUNDRED IN TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND GIVEN HARD EACH AND
HER HUSBAND GAVE FIFTY THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED. I AM VERY NEW SOME
GAVE TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED.
MEMBERS ASPIRIN I'VE VOTE TODAY
TO CONTINUE OUR STATE
LONGSTANDING REPUTATION A PRETTY
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OUR POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
AND THERE ARE NO WITNESSES THANK
YOU YES WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
AS A REMINDER THE PUBLIC LAST
FIFTEEN MINUTES IN TOTAL. FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT ALL
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ARE LIMITED
TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME. THE
ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT. AND
THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL I
WILL START IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHETHER ANY WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SEVEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR DOZEN WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SEVEN
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHICH IS TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO SEVEN. IF
U. S. S. BIGGEST SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AT FIRST WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THEY HAVE REMOVED
ITSELF FROM Q. ONE MOMENT. WE
HAVE JUST ONE MARKET IN THEIR
LINE NUMBER AT AT THE MOMENT
HERE. THANK YOU. AND WITH THAT
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIANS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS-
SACRAMENTO COUNTY GREEN PARTY
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MATTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE CAN THERE I'M IN FAVOR.
THERE ARE FURTHER NO FURTHER
CALLS IN QUEUE THANK YOU. WE
ALSO DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SO WILL MOVE TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. AGAIN
AS A REMINDER FIFTEEN MINUTES IN
TOTAL FOR ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ARE ALSO
LIMITED TO PROVIDING THEIR NAME
THE ORGANIZATION THEY REPRESENT
AND THEIR POSITION ON THE BILL.
WILL START ON THE COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS ANYBODY IN
THIS ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO TWO SEVEN.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR DIFFERENT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AB TWO
TWO SEVEN. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IS
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
NO LIGHTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND I'M
OF THE BILL. MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL SARDO SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO- SINGING HEARING NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES MICHAEL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI THIS
BILL HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECCO THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND PRESENTING
FOR US TODAY MADAM SECRETARY CAN
WE CALL VOTE. BRYAN AT BRIAN.
ARTILLERY SAY ARCHER I BENNETT.
BENNETT I LOW WELL I CERVANTES
CERVANTES MULLIN MULLIN I BLANCA
RUBIO BLANCA RUBIO I. THE BILL
WITHOUT SEVEN THEIR- GET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. FOR THE
NEXT ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS A. B.
NINE SEVEN TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN FAMILIAR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TO THIS COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY. AND WELCOME
BACK. YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL
. SURE BRIAN IT IS WONDERFUL TO
SEE YOU UP THERE. AND LET ME
START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF OF FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS BILL MORE SO A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO- THAN THIS YEAR BUT-
YOU GOT YOU GOT SOME OF THE BEST
IN THE BUSINESS SO- REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S WORKING.
DEEPFAKES ARE EXTREMELY
CONVINCING FABRICATED PHOTOS
VIDEOS AND AUDIO RECORDINGS OF
SOMEONE APPEARING TO SAY OR DO
SOMETHING THEY DID NOT. THE
ABILITY TO ATTRIBUTE SPEECH AND
CONDUCT TO A POLITICAL CANDIDATE
THAT IS FALSE THAT NEVER
HAPPENED. MAKES DEPICTS A
POWERFUL AND DANGEROUS TOOL IN
THEARSENAL OF THOSE THAT WANT
TO WAGE MIS AND DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS. WHICH IS WHY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED MY AB SEVEN
THIRTY. A NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL
TO PROHIBIT THE DISTRIBUTION OF
DEEPFAKES AND OTHER MANIPULATED
MEDIA. WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF AN
ELECTION. UNLESS THE IMAGE OR
RECORDING INCLUDED DISCLOSURE
STATING THAT IT IS MANIPULATED.
NOTABLY THE BILL INCLUDED A
JANUARY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SONS. PROVISION THIS. THEN
THESUNSET TO JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN. KEEPING
THE LAW INTACT FOR AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE YEARS. ACTION ADDITIONAL
FOUR YEARS. DOING SO WILL
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTIONS IN THE COMING YEARS AS
DEEPFAKE TECHNOLOGY ADVANCES AND
BECOMES EVEN MORE MAINSTREAM. AB
SEVEN THIRTY RECEIVED WIDESPREAD
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. VOTERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THE
MEDIA THEY'RE BEING SHOWN IS
REAL OR FAKE- AND EVER. ASK FOR
. SOME OF THE- PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT AGAIN FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT AND
POSITION ON THE BILL WILL STAR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM THIS IN
SUPPORT. AB NOW. SINAN WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES WERE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINE SEVEN TWO MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON THE LINE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF AB NINE SEVEN TWO. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS STAR. I'M SORRY ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE DO HAVE
LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
BUT. MOVING OUT WE HAVE LINE
THIRTY- PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IN THE OTHER DAY MY YOUNG
WITH POLITICAL SOLUTION I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE
. I WANT TO GET IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER OUTLINED TO Q. I THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
THIS IS AN OPPOSITE OF THIS
BILL. AGAIN I DON'T SEE ANY
PRIMARY WHICH IS IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILLS WILL MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. FIFTEEN
MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. WILL STAR IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM IS THERE ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AB NINE SEVEN TWO.
SEEING NONE WILL OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR DIFFERENT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE LINE IN OFFICE.
AB NINE. WHAT OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AT THE CENTER ON THE LINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON. TO QUESTION
THE COME FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THIS
COMMITTEE. SECOND I HAVE MOVED
THE BILL HEARD BY THE MEMBER LOW
SEGMENT BY SOME ANY THEIR
COMMUNISM OVER IT YET THEY DO IT
I JUST LIKE TO- APPLAUDED THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND POINT OUT
THAT AS TECHNOLOGY EVOLVES I'M
SURE THIS LAW IS GOING TO HAVE
TO EVOLVE AND SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE IS A SENSE MOSTLY
FORCE US TO KEEP UPDATING IT AND
I'M SURE YOU'RE GONNA BE ON TOP
OF THAT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
BENEFITS THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MEDITECH TAKING
THE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BRIAN HI. BRIAN I SAY
OUR TELEVOTING. THERE ARE TWO IS
NOT VOTING. BENNETT BENNETT HI
LO. LO I CERVANTES. CERVANTES I
MULLIN. MULLIN I BLANCA RUBIO
BUT THE RUBIO I. SIX EYES WERE
NOT VOTING THE BILL GETS UP
PROJECT THANKS VERY MUCH THANK
IS ANYMORE. NEXT ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA IS AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR
CALLING US TODAY IN MULTIPLE
CAPACITIES. YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES ARE TODAY I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH SEVEN WHICH WILL
CREATE AN INDEPENDENT CITIZENS
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BEGINNING WITH
TWENTY THIRTY ROUND OF
REDISTRICTING. I DO WANNA A
FIRST ROUND BYE ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE SUGGESTED AMENDED BY
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE NINE
THROUGH ELEVEN. SERVICE I DO
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR OTHER WORK AND
ASSISTANCE ON THIS VERY BILL. I
DO ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT I WILL
BE LOCKED. HAS THE SAME HER THIS
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
THIS BILL GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. WE AS MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE DO NOT GET TO
DRAW OUR OWN DISTRICTS WHY